bro
food
number four there's three men before me
and there's another man with an actual
name before that
so i'm number five at this point yeah
yeah yeah yeah so there's andre there's
andrew number one to three
one two and three and then there's me
number four
who had four
nah the audacity
[Music]
okay
okay guys
oh it is monday again and we are happy
like absolutely buzzing to have you with
us
we're going to be opening honestly we're
four shots of tequila deep deep we're
four shots
on a monday afternoon yeah yeah yeah
yeah we don't know what's going on
there's no windows in here as well it
doesn't help
yeah so hotbox four shots to kill a deep
it's nuts shit's getting funny when it
shouldn't be funny
we're inspired
um
yeah your boys are your boys are making
moves yeah
before we turned on we were two shots of
tequila deep and then before we turn on
the camera we've got a cheeky little
email
and it's
you you know your boys are in it for the
bags yeah we love you man yeah
give me this let's cut the [ __ ] off of
course of course we're in it for the
bags the bags the papers yeah so we've
got a young little email yeah mum bags
bags so we decided to drape out the
tequila again for the second time today
yeah
so it's whatever it is yeah man so if
shit's a little bit incoherent today you
know why you know why it's all jokey
jokes um
guys obviously you already know the
drill if you want to
enjoy the fun vibes
twice a week instead of once you need to
pause this video right now you need to
head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs and then
you're going to drop a little three
pound a month
temperature tempe a day run run the p
and then you're gonna enjoy our company
twice twice so we can set it once
really really simple um go in there
enjoy yourself
and if you're not about it that's fine
bro
that's like yeah it's literally fine
i have no judgments but you're just
missing out yeah you're missing out like
now you hate fun clearly but that's fine
again we don't judge we're an
all-inclusive community you're a [ __ ]
but again we don't judge all-inclusive
community we love you anyway um guys if
you're watching on youtube right now we
need you to head on over to the big red
button and click that actually click it
don't just re look at the video and then
hear me say
big red button quickly glance down at it
and then carry on watching the video
take the mouse and click click subscribe
it takes you nothing yeah it does
wonders for us and it doesn't
change anything change your life it
doesn't change your life it's a massive
impact for us and it's a real real like
easy move for you guys so we'd really
appreciate it if you do it if you don't
do it again fine no judgments but we
really like it if you did again also
we're going to do
is take the two power fingers of death
give it a
moisturize
is it this and then flick that bean ring
that belt
slap the notifications on okay yeah man
yeah you need to know every time we're
running stuff you just need to know
um
further from that guys your boys are now
in the top
10
comedy podcast in the country that's an
actual fact that's a fact that's a fact
bro that's just spotify
let's not talk about google let's not
talk about apple let's not even talk
about youtube
let's not even discuss tick tock okay
because that's just not fair it's not
fair it doesn't make sense and yeah like
i'm i'm on it right now
and i'm not don't even have to scroll
down i can see shits and gigs in the top
10 top comedy podcasts in the uk yeah
that's not even all 10. that's just the
first half of the ten oops
[Laughter]
top 10 is spotify yups
i've said so much
so now guys
you're always caught up in the social
media and stuff like that like yes you
guys are in top 10 in spotify yes the
sidemen stay in our dms yes do we have
the biggest
uk podcast tick tock account
ever
ah [ __ ] sake yeah bro we don't but the
thing is we don't punch down so there
are a lot of other guys that that look
look at us at
up and we don't want to punch down okay
so don't think about the numbers think
about the engagement think about the
culture think about the cult okay that's
all the matters they're called man so on
that note chirps a ting in the comments
let's get some breeding grounds together
let's all come together as a community
and let's just let's just love each
other yeah okay let's go for
1 000 likes on this video a thousand
likes
next monday i want to see a thousand
likes on this video it's so basic
so yeah let's go let's do it um but yeah
guys obviously thank you for for
sticking with us for so long
um we're we're super happy to have you
here and without further ado
firelord fuegs is gonna run a train on
these facts um oh actually no no before
he does hit me quick announcement um i
said it on the patreon episode but you
guys probably weren't there
so while most of you wonder you're boys
in the market for a new barber it's been
a long time coming i've been
mugged off smacked about and degraded
yep for too long now yep yep yeah yeah
a few prerequisites
this barber needs to be based in
birmingham mm-hmm preferably city center
ce center i'm flexible within a couple
miles probably probably five mile radius
depending on the talent
but preferably city center birmingham
yeah yeah i want to come to birmingham
on a monday i want to get my trim i want
to get my gym and then i want to record
with my boy so preferably monday
birmingham
he needs to be lit he needs to get it
done in 35 he or she
if it's a she preferably banging
preferably body od have you see i see a
tick tock the other day
with the cheeks the barber she got fatty
i've not seen a tick tock i've seen a
picture oh i've seen a picture of a
chick i've seen
the tick tock i was talking about was a
guy getting a trim and it was two yeah
twerking in his face
i've not seen that i've yeah i saw that
on tick tock but i have seen the picture
oh and the caption is my son's been to
the barbers three times this week so
she's been like that there there was a a
female barber with body oddie
so preferably if it's female body oddie
flirtatious but not invasive yeah not
aggressive professional professional not
flirty yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
know that one yeah yeah if it's not
that's fine again talented you can get
it done in 35 can do a high top and a
low fade
shape up needs to be gnarly
don't rely on the spray thing preferably
my don's don't do a spray thing on me if
you need to do it for your own
self-esteem fine but light
yeah light they need to keep the waves
intact don't abuse my waves yeah they're
naturally formed
[Laughter]
don't abuse my waves they're naturally
formed um is there any prerequisites
if it says on the on the tin they open
at half nine hey this is it's a black
business
i'll give you to 950 yeah i'm max yeah
yeah yeah yeah but you need to be open
when i get there so guys
your boys on the market if you have a
buff
uh barber in birmingham that you want to
recommend to me i'm going to need their
name and address i need to know which
[ __ ] guy it is 100 don't just tell me
a shot i need to know which bread i'm
going to yeah and i need to see your
trim yep so those guys slide in my
personal dms let me know um and i'd love
to i'd love to move over because my barb
is abusing my trust and i'm sick of it
okay so guys that's it
it's out there i'm on the market for a
new barber please hit me up and let me
know
now without any further ado firelord
fuegs is here with the firelord facts
facts
all right this ties in well with us
actually
so um do you know patricia bright
probably
okay
let's just get something straight
i'm fairly certain i have a
level of um dementia
that prevents me from remembering names
okay but you know so his name names
literally mean unless you're in like
this circle yeah names mean nothing to
you yeah yeah i don't know your name
so yeah faces i can never get a face
okay this girl you look look familiar
cool oh wait was she on steven
bartlett's podcast yes she was yeah then
yes okay so let's i'll take it back
i'll take it then yes
then yes of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'll take it back so she's in the um
content creating industry as well she
does youtube and all that stuff so the
entrepreneur also millionaire creator
patricia bright the entrepreneur who
built an empire through content creation
she started youtube as a hobby and while
she was an intern in 2009 she left her
50 000 pounds a year paying job to be a
full-time youtuber at 26. it took her
three years to start earning real money
on youtube she now has two channels with
3 million subscribers and 350 over 350
million views
on the two collectively one is a
lifestyle channel and one's a finance
channel she surpassed 1 million pounds
in earnings from ad revenue sponsors and
her own product her own products and
courses
this ties in well with us brother
well with us speaking of
do you
have any idea you wouldn't to be fair
because i don't really talk about this
kind of stuff of you do you have any
idea how much
finance uh youtube channels make
right
no do you know how much [ __ ] money
they make no
so
here's a little fun fact for anyone
who's um
interested in getting into youtube who
doesn't necessarily understand how the
money works is like a little insight
yeah
so
youtube works on a
a statistic not a statistic but they
they work on what they call cpm right
so cpm
means cost per melee which is latin for
basically
how much money per thousand views
so youtube will pay you a certain amount
of money for every thousand views you
get
now that money per thousand is dependent
on the budget of the
businesses that
want to advertise on youtube
so if you have a very small business
with a very low budget
um
they don't get much choice if your
budget is low you don't really get much
choice about what
channel you want to advertise yourself
on if you want to have a specific choice
of channel you want to advertise on
let's say i am an insurance company or
let's say i'm a stock investment or
forex or crypto company and i've got a
massive budget and i want to make sure
that the audience that i'm targeting my
budget towards are the right audience
ergo people who are watching finance
youtube channels youtube channels yeah
your cpm is going to be higher yeah so
the average cpm
is usually anywhere between
3 and i wanna say
seven or eight pounds
so yeah between three and eight pounds
per thousand views
uh we usually dependent sometimes we're
about seven eight sometimes we're about
four or five depending on the kind of
videos that we're putting out
um i i try not to think about too much
it is what it is we talk about what we
talk about the money comes regardless
[ __ ] it just put it out there there's no
point trying to make an episode because
it's going to happen like
but
finance
is usually top tier
real estate and finance those kind of
companies have huge sometimes tech but
those companies have huge budgets
when they come to youtube for their
advertising
so
i've seen videos
with a cpm of
35 pounds
per thousand views
wow
wow and somebody obviously those views
get like millions upon a couple of
millions upon big commands so
if you're in the in the in the brand of
talking [ __ ] about whatever you want to
talk about if you're in the i specialize
in [ __ ] board games youtube channel
space
and all these people have incredibly low
budgets and you're on a
like i don't know a three pound 50 cpm
for every three pound fifty you make
the next predator that's talking about
crypto is making 35
pounds bro
for every 350 you make they make 35.
[ __ ] you know fam [ __ ] you so every time
you make so let's say what you make 10
000 views you've made a young 35 pounds
they've made 350.
100 000 views
you've made 350 pounds they've made
three thousand five hundred pounds
damn
different difference yeah so yeah sorry
to the long digression there huge
difference but yeah bro um um it's
breaking cake it breaks down her thing
as well because obviously i told you
she's got a lifestyle channel and a
finance channel i'm assuming her
lifestyle channel is the one that's
called patricia bright and she's got
2.86 million subscribers she started
this one in 2009 she has over 352
million views collectively
her finance channel is called the break
she has just under half a million
subscribers she started on march the 8th
2018
and she's just got she's got over just
18 million views on that one as well
yeah i wouldn't be surprised she makes
more money online on the break that she
does on the other one yeah because
there's this
sponsored specific adverts on her on
that page
will be ridiculous
ridiculous disgusting bro ridiculous
disgusting bro yeah man for those that
don't know about how money works in
youtube there's a little intake on that
yeah a little insight but yeah my best
advice was don't start a channel because
you think it's gonna have a high cpa
yeah
because i don't think anyone's you'll
wanna yeah not that anyone does but when
you hear numbers like that yeah yeah
yeah
it
it can it can persuade you to well i
don't think it will persuade someone to
start a channel but i think it would
dissuade someone
who like i said
is really into [ __ ] yo-yos
and they want to make a yo-yo youtube
channel and they're like yeah but
if i make a youtube channel even if it's
really successful i'm going to be making
a penny on the pound for what these guys
are making so there's no point i just
wouldn't want it to dissuade anyone from
doing something they want to do because
they don't think they're going to be
making
optimal
finance
fair enough yeah finance channels make
[ __ ] connections i can imagine it's
disgusting
man it's disgusting one of these days
yeah so when you see i'm just gonna say
don't be surprised
in in two years from now yeah when
you're seeing your your regular shits
and gig stuff yeah and then a random
little playlist just tweaks out yeah and
it's me and gucci shades
and i'm wearing a pinstripe suit and
then and it's got our logo all the way
through the suit and i'm sat here with
[ __ ] grant cardone
and i'm talking real estate
and i got the foggies about what i'm
talking about you know just chat i'm a
different
don't be surprised and don't be shy to
watch it yeah gucci shades
from when i'm gucci down to the socks
yeah and i'm chatting bear reader state
and crypto for no reason it's not even
coherent yeah the sentences don't make
sense i just keep saying crypto
just the sound of money yeah yeah yeah i
keep saying nft and crypto and
investments
yeah yeah when i keep saying index funds
yeah that's like you know your channel
yeah
that's all you that's all you need to
know
but yeah um
nice job that's [ __ ] interesting so
yeah
sh herpe is her piece cake her p is is
different yeah very very very different
before
before we go to um
the next topic we're gonna go on the
most awkward thing
i'm gonna make
one
right turn elsewhere and bring up an ick
you should i'm going to do one ick
someone said i can't remember if they
said it to me or send it to us but it
said it's an egg that egg themselves
okay
and i read it
and
this had this must have happened to
every human being it must have okay
because it's happened to me oh okay it's
happened to me
they called my name i put my hands up
yeah you have to yeah you're a man you
have to put your hands up it's happened
to me before so
the biggest ick right
you've done taking a [ __ ]
yeah i'm already but go on
you get the toilet paper you fold it up
or whatever
you do your wipe
but the toilet paper breaks and your
middle finger slaps your [ __ ]
that's probably happened to me like
two to three times in my entire life but
every time it's memorable for me it's
happened to me it's happening bam
because you you pull your finger out and
it's shaking and that nail
a man said if i'm that nail
it looks like that fingers in quarantine
because it's always either this one or
this one oh one other two it's
completely like your joint moves in a
way you didn't know you could because
this fingers here now
by itself you have to isolate it from
your pack
matter the middle fingers in isolation
it's working from home cousins yeah
family oh bro i read that i was like
what an ick oh incredible and ick bro
i read that i was like yeah man yeah man
i can't remember if it wasn't mine if it
was ours i saw it i was like
fair play it could have been a comment
on a tick tock i don't remember i read
it i was like rags wow
that's happened you know what it's
myself actually i don't even know if i
could say it bro
[ __ ] it
you know if i'm you know when you've got
a bad tummy okay yeah and you bust
doodoo yeah and you're pretty certain
that it's just done
you know what it's done yeah
but you you do your thing you grab your
tissue yeah yeah you fold them and wrap
them whatever yeah and you go to swipe
and the thing slips off
because
you've been busting doo-doo bro
so it's just wet it's just
caked
and then you
you're wrapping
and you think it's going to be a one
white thing or two white thing and if
i'm using seven eight seven eight later
oh yeah you're just like oh [ __ ] kill
me after that first swipe you're just
like there's a lot kill me bro
just do it
yeah
yeah man the worst one
or one of the worst one is
when you're doing your thing you're
taking a [ __ ] whatever you're wiping
wiping wiping you think you're done you
stand up you flush
and then you feel your stomach bubbling
again oh no i can't deal with that you
feel your stomach because when you feel
sometimes when you sit down and you
think you're done or when you throw up
as well when you think you're done
i can breathe now you stand up flush
whatever
your stomach says no damn times i'm
getting in the shower because i know
there's nothing left
so i need i i literally turn the hottest
shower on i can bear and i get in there
and i just feel like it needs to
rejuvenate me i need to remind my body
that's alive do you know me
i need to cleanse whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah because i'm not sitting down
again
i just think like you need to get your
act together yeah because i'm not
sitting down again with this bubbly
belly that's hilarious it's [ __ ]
butters but yeah that's a disgusting
yeah anyway um
let's let's pull back together we'll
pull back to the main
um so last week i asked you guys on or
we asked you guys on instagram um most
awkward thing that happened to you on a
date obviously it was [ __ ] jokes we
put bears on the actual social but there
was like hundreds and hundreds that i
couldn't post because it was too long
we've got them here i'm going to read
some out so let's go
all right actually let me get ready to
laugh
in fact i want to take my top off cool
i'm gonna get hot
i saw someone say this is a nick what
when he takes off his jumper and he
pulls his arms out first
instead of like this instead of just
chucking it over yeah yeah but i'm on
camera sorry
i think you're [ __ ]
do you think my belly button is going on
i'm sorry
you're mad
that's a personal it you'll never see my
belly button on youtube
i swear to god you'll never see my belly
button on youtube until
um
until your boy's in a physical space
yeah where these men have no choice
because the crowds want to see it
when the veins are veining yeah yeah
yeah the striations are straight yeah
then my belly button will peekaboo
[ __ ] off say less all right raise it off
go all right cool this one i put on the
actual instagram yeah yeah but this is
an honorary mention i'll have to read
this out again this deserves a double
take go go go go go
but the thing is well
um full disclosure i didn't read any of
them okay i have no idea what you put
okay okay until you didn't look okay
perfect so whatever is whatever perfect
well for the for the fandom that have
seen the ones on youtube um that we've
got posted on ig and i'm reading this
one this is an honorary mention i think
i've got a couple i don't mention but
this one
sent to me bro okay so
tell what was the question the question
again is most awkward thing that's
happened to you on a date
right
okay okay
right
the guy pulled out my tampon
and threw it across the room when i said
we couldn't have sex
nah
what's he on yanked out the tampon and
dashed it he fam
he was
drunk or high or something he thought it
was romantic
i could not have been that woman what
did that even feel like i fam
i could not have been that woman bro
that just doesn't make sense to him it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
to me how
someone can allow not even necessarily
allow because i'm assuming she didn't
allow you to have a choice she'd have a
choice that was a purely reaction
it got yanked out she gasped
because i just don't understand bro the
thing is what persuade a man to do that
if i was the bread
i'm trying to empathize where his head
space was at
i'm trying i'm trying emphasis on the
strike right
but where it would stop for me is when i
see it
i know because these things swell up
i'm saying yeah it doesn't look like it
went going in as well when it comes to
coming out yeah so it might if you if
you thought it was a whole romantic
thing yeah i thought [ __ ] it yeah i want
to let her know i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
this is on a period as soon as i yank it
out and the thing's this big
however my whole body will shake and i
would have to dash it
out of fear more than anything and i'm
like sorry
and you're right
you were right in the first place yeah
she'd want to bang you in the face
you didn't believe me before
she'd want to bang you in the face
nah
yeah nah it's it's just not on yeah that
was the honor you mentioned a hat
that's disgraceful
all right again most awkward thing
that's happened to you one day remember
that yeah
someone asked me if i knew how to wax
backs because his mum normally did it
on a date
can you wax her back family how does
that even come into conversation bro
what are you looking for second of all
why does your mum do it he ain't got a
choice g he ain't got a choice nah he
has he has got a choice yeah to be fair
he's got a thai
lady down the road that will do it he's
got a choice your mother doesn't have to
do it if you're dating someone you're
right
you're old enough to make your own
decisions yeah yeah yeah do you know
what i mean so he decided to ask his
mother he's been enclosed all his life
it's just nah just now wow now can you
wax her back
nah
speaking of wax before i continue with
this thing i've started a new show um
it's been highly recommended to me but
by someone um it's called good girls i
don't even see it on netflix before good
girls yeah
so the premise of the show is it's um
about three women they're all in like
this they've all they're all
got that they're separate situations but
they all come together because they've
got famous people in it uh i'm only on
season one so i wouldn't say no i'm on
season two halfway through things
there's not famous people in it maybe
i'm thinking about something else in my
head but then again in my head i'm
thinking of a movie no it's a series
yeah exactly so maybe it's wrong maybe
i'm thinking of something else
maybe i'll talk about i don't know i
feel like in my head i've got i've got
um
what's my man what's my girl's name
um
from forgetting sarah marshall
the main chick no
not sarah marshall i'm never going to
remember the new the other one she's
famous mila kunis mila kuni she's
banging
she is in a weird way yeah she's banging
um i'm sure there's a movie we've heard
it sounds like something called good
girls or something like that but never
mind anyway i'm digressing for no reason
premise of the show is um they all have
their separate situations but they all
need money so they end up like
doing some drug [ __ ] or like getting
laundry money and blah blah so they're
well in deep with this thing from this
this is sounding more like the thing i'm
talking about
it sounds exactly like the thing i'm
talking about it's these two let me just
google this [ __ ] bro
good girls
who's in this thing family maybe
millionaires isn't season five oh wow
there's not a single famous person in
this ignore me fam
let me type in mila kunis
a good girl i'm ruining the whole thing
bro i'm sorry i need to know what she's
been in miner she looks old now isn't it
here i've not seen her wow
is she with ashton no i think so yeah
bad moms
i may have seen bad moms came out 2016
oh wow
i thought it was newer than that but
yeah similar premise
i've had a [ __ ] eyebrow anyway it
just reminded me of a good girl sorry
i'm sorry but yeah it's neither here nor
there that's literally there the fam is
what i'm saying about the incoherency of
the the tequila yeah i'm just chatting
about nothing it is what it is they love
it we love it go on
um that's the premise of the show but
there's a scene in one maybe like
episode one or episode two one of the
main chicks
um she's she's a great actress in the in
the show by the way she knows how to set
a tone oh it's crazy okay crazy okay and
the sexual tension you know i'm like
yeah i know you're the sexual touch
between her and the druggie oh
family the drug the drug oh wow
yeah okay
what kind of drugs are we talking about
oh no they do the drugs they just handle
the money the yachts handle the money
yeah i'm saying but what drugs is he
into uh we have no way i have no
if there's a heroin addict and there's a
section of that's going to confuse me
but he's not an addict he just does the
shot in
he okay listen to me fam
okay let's just let's just address this
a drug gee yeah it's not a dealer that's
i meant the dealer okay cool right
that's why i said drug and you said the
drug e
so that's why i i was confirming
whether it was a dealer maybe the
drugger yeah yeah
the drugger not the druggie yeah the
druggie is the addict yeah the drug
the supplier that's why i said what
drugs are we talking about the supplier
there's a plastic surprise that makes
sense there's there's a mystery and
what's she doing cooking
no no she she launders the money oh
she's just yeah she's just about the
money she launders the money so all
three of them lost
type of situation similar yeah similar
but a light a lot lighter oh it's like
oh it's dark yeah
we're going into season four soon soon
there's going to be a refresh in that
next episode also so watch out watch
anyway the point i was getting at
[ __ ] now the point i was getting
because we were talking about these wax
backs tanks yeah yeah the point i was
getting episode one episode two
recommend which one it was what this
yacht was on all fours in a wax intake
i've never i've never actually
comprehended how waxing works in terms
of the positions they have to get in
what they have to wear blah blah this
[ __ ] was on all fours and just like an
oversized tee all fours are like doggy
style she was mid-talking conversation
with the lady and she just yanked her
gooch bruv
i was thinking is this what women
actually do for us obviously not not
just for us obviously for them as well
but it's for us mainly for us it's for
us they wouldn't put themselves through
that for fun and i'm thinking is this
what you might have to go through that's
not on bro
it's just what you have to go through on
a weekly monthly whatever basis
mandom as well man i'm doing as well
family
fam she shuddered
yanked the hair from her gooch
i couldn't believe what i was watching
now i understand why like
women
take it so personally when guys [ __ ]
them about oh yeah
if you waste their time
if they've made all the effort and you
say oh babe
tonight always time
i waxed for this
i don't think you understand all the
sense now it makes all the sense it
makes all the sense in the world bro bro
what are you talking about you can't
make it fam
i'm sorry
yeah i was on all fours earlier today in
pain for this [ __ ] yeah she yanked it
off
shuddered nah that's all right but
anyway next up anyway
um
blah blah okay
i accidentally accidentally said i love
you during the deed i drove home in
silence afterwards oh [ __ ] sake
do you know if that was a guy or a girl
i can't remember i didn't know i didn't
write like girl either way either way is
tough either way is tough this was a guy
that wrote this one obviously watch
he told the waiter no there was a girl
that wrote this one but a guy said this
he told the waiter
she'll have a salad she needs it
i never spoke to him
what fun
she
she what a salad she needs it she needs
it
i know this is not a date that
i don't understand so many things i read
i couldn't comprehend bro i couldn't wow
wow
i'll force feed in the salad when it
arrives
and i'm yanking this rib eye
i'm yanking this rib and i'll force
feeding the lettuce
all right
realized we had gone to a gay bar
seven men asked for his number
i was asked to leave
[Laughter]
yo [ __ ] that made me cough i was asked
to leave
nah
that's not on bro this one for some
reason
sweeted me a goal
because it just doesn't make sense all
right say let's go on rolls were
reversed okay
one liner she tried to give me flowers
on the date
the audacity i would be so offended i
don't know why though
in 2022 i don't know why that would piss
me off so much
and the thing is there's nothing there's
nothing you can do in that situation
which is worldly white will piss me off
so much to take your dignity back
because if she walks up at your door
yeah and gives you flowers if i accept
them yeah i mean yeah if i slam the door
in her face
[Music]
there's nothing you can do it just
didn't make sense bro oh [ __ ]
that's annoying
another one-liner
he wore slazinger backless trainers
what's a backless trainer
that's hilarious neither i didn't know
backless crep was a thing i've heard of
a crock she a slassinger
trainer to the date
nah nah nah nah
right he works in tech
again i can't i don't i can't remember
if this is a guy or a girl because it
the way it's worded it could be either
one
catfished huge i was thirsty though
drove around the corner smashed got
dropped home
you don't know if there's a girl i can't
remember if it was a guy but either way
catfished but i was
huge
i was thirsty drove around the corner
smashed dropped home definitely a girl
that's right
it was a girl that got picked up
was horny
vex about it drove around the corner
because
a guy could never finesse that a guy
like a girl could easily
be like
let's go around the block quickly
[ __ ] and then drop me home a girl could
do that to anyone
and get away get away with it a guy
could never be like let's go around the
corner
i'm gonna bang you then you better drop
me home
can you imagine a guy trying to say that
can you imagine nah
can you imagine the twitter feed oh bro
he's on shade room tomorrow
now he's a predator nah
yeah [ __ ] hell
took me to a thai restaurant and told me
women are just
wait wait wait
wait wait go
so this is a guy to a girl right
took me to a thai restaurant
and told me women are just snakes with
tits
[Laughter]
[Applause]
women are snakes with tits
wow
jesus christ
oh we bumped into his friends and he
asked me what my name was again
that's a power play
fab
i'm not gonna lie to you this never
happened to me on like a date
like scenario kind of thing but my
short-term memory with names is
horrendous bro i think that's a joke
horrendous anyone's name bro like like
this happens to me at work a lot i'm
talking talking talking talking talking
about what's your name they asked me
i'll say foohard and they say oh what's
your i say what's your name he could say
jamal she could say shannon she could
say this fam literally five seconds
after i've forgotten oh 100 that's me
every day of my life
if i need if i need to remember your
name
i will know before
i will know before i'm going up to you
that i need to remember your name
because how bad my memory is so that i'm
saying i need to remember i need to
remember yeah what's
my name bro my name like cognitive
ability is off yeah i fully hear you
it's bad fully fully fully fully eu it's
so bad fully bro
[ __ ] you know
i had a first tinder date and we watched
a film of mine he sat and
he sat and watched
not watch so he sat and ate a whole tub
of coleslaw with a spoon
with a spoon
[Laughter]
just coleslaw
this is what she said not even a fork as
well with a spoon brother
with a spoon a coleslaw with a spoon
bro people go through it i'm speechless
the streets aren't reliable they're not
slightly they're not they're not they're
not they're not they're not they're not
they're just not they're just not
now i know why people consistently go
back to the ex
makes sense
i just don't want to be here this one
will make you want to go back to it say
let's hit me
i might raise them
date was okay so the date was being long
in the toilet i bailed her phone but she
left it at the table
i was saved as food number four
bro
food
number four there's three men before me
and there's another man with an actual
name before that
so i'm number five at this point yeah
yeah yeah so there's andre there's andre
number one one two three
one two and three and then there's me
number four
who had four
stars
the audacity
i
oh i want to confront her so bad but i
need to leave then and there you'd have
oh
uh i would have to leave unleash level
with the bill bro you know what just
leave her with him just a slightly
digressive yeah he hit me hit me here
this is an interesting thing right so
there is a podcast
that i see clips of a lot it's called
fresh and fit
okay and basically the premises this is
these two breasts it's based out of
miami
and their like goal per se is to prepare
men for the streets in these regards
okay so just be like aware that a lot of
women have an agenda and they use dating
and they use their attractiveness to get
the best out of men to get the best to
get the best out of men but to get the
best out of a situation to get what they
want out of a situation so in that
example if they want food i know i can
get free food because i'm paying and
just they're just their their goal is to
make men aware that that is a thing
and when you're when you're when you're
meeting a girl you should be self-aware
in terms of like wait is this they said
this is a show right it's a real podcast
it's a real podcast is this podcast
hosted by women or men men oh
two men but
they often invite women onto their panel
to discuss these things
and a lot of the women that come on are
green like yeah bro if like if you're
caked and you're butters
and i want to write and i've never been
on a yacht
guess what
i'm getting on your yacht yeah because i
have no interest in [ __ ] you i have
no interest in dating you but like i've
never been on a yacht and i know my
looks will get me on a yacht
so basically their their aim is to
make men aware that guys that this is a
real reality so if like if you're if
you're
basically if you're a bum
you need to do x y and zed
to impress people more mm-hmm um and if
you are wealthy and ugly like you can't
just be meeting a buffeting and
expecting that she likes you for you you
need to be prepared for the possibility
that that's not the case yeah and i've
seen a lot of their clips on tick tock
and stuff that i think is i don't
actually even like their show okay like
i don't like their mentality and i don't
like their show and there's a lot of
stuff about the stuff that they say and
their energy that i just don't like okay
they're toxic dudes okay like when you
see a lot of their clips you're just
like you piss me off and i would
actually like to be on your panel yeah
to be like bro you piss me off yeah
because of x y and z yeah
it annoys me but that that that there is
a factor of what they say ergo food
number four that's actually a legitimate
issue
that's painful that's very painful
because pain you can
there's four men before me
yo
that's [ __ ] hilarious bro i didn't
even think about the bear with the name
the bread with the name is the main at
least one brother at least one bread
with the name
wow andre like you said bro and the
thing is you're not even dick for your
food for four
i'll take you up to benihana to the show
to this to that and i'm just food for
you yeah yeah yeah yeah i paid the bill
and dipped oh babe do you want to go
back to my baby's not tonight i got
early morning blah blah blah i could say
like see in a couple weeks yeah bro and
that's it food number four post
shangri-la she's at dick two
can you imagine oh
disgraceful that's hurt my chest more
than i will ever be able to describe
please continue it's not it's it's so
unfair
[Music]
hmm
i fingered a girl once and all i could
smell was [ __ ] oh my god hold on hold on
i tried to put my fingers in her mouth
and she slapped me
so obviously
i'm afraid he was stinks and pops yeah
he was thinking also and she fought
not preferable but all right all right
and then you tried to
you're taking a [ __ ] fist
climb
that's hilarious that's hilarious
all right we'll do one more
yeah yeah oh we'll do one more and then
we'll keep it moving
right he leaned in for a kiss or lent in
for a kiss rather sorry chickened out
kept on leaning and then kissed my knee
through my ripped jeans
oh my god
that is that's enough to make me vomit
yeah
that's enough
to make me
vomit you're a [ __ ] like
like you know when you want to grab
someone to shake up yeah like you're a
you're beyond a [ __ ] yeah you're a
[ __ ] boy
you're a [ __ ] boy uh
speaking of [ __ ] boy you know how i
love to do my honorary mentions
yeah create like create appreciation yes
yes yes yes there's another tick tock
car he's friends with the one i
mentioned last week cole anderson okay
this guy gets enough flowers yeah but
he's got this one like so basically his
name's jack joseph okay english guys
he does like skits and he has a few
characters that he repeats okay
and
um
he he has one that you've probably seen
he does like undercover fed series is
that when you run into an undercover fed
um
maybe let me search for him now
jack joseph jack joseph okay i think the
first one i came up to before oh yeah
he's got like two million followers he's
a busy guy he's white brother yeah yeah
so ah
yeah i've seen the undercover thing i've
seen the undercover thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah one that's like oh when you
run into a pick me boy
okay bro there's one in there they're in
the they're filming in the woods or
saturn yeah a man says
ah i can't remember
he says something along the lines of
like
if you were a transformer you'd be
optimus prime or sat into the to the
chick yeah a mass says
the way he says it yeah it's not it's
annoying because i'm never going to be
able to say it yeah to be funny the way
he says it yeah but man rolls up to her
and he's like oh hello my lady and like
kisses her hand kind of thing it's like
has anyone ever told you like something
along the lines of like i'm butchering
it but it's like ah if you were a
transformer like you'd be optimus prime
and he's always like because he's like
he's got this [ __ ]
[ __ ] mentality just pick me in
mentality he's like
if i was a
transformer i'd probably be he'd go he
goes i'll probably be optimus fugly
and then he looks up and this guy goes
optimus batty boy
i watched it last weekend and i swear to
god
i couldn't stand up
i was hunched bro
optimus patty boy
is the funniest thing i've ever heard
wow the fact the fact that someone could
think of that yeah optimus battery boy
nah
bro is that a recent vid i have to
figure out this it's recent i have to
find that vid
i guarantee i could probably i'll send
it to you because if i see it i'll know
which one it is yeah yeah yeah
fam
optimus battery boy you know optimus
[ __ ] no get it he gets views as well
oh fam he gets views busy busy
uh i can find it hang on hang on hang on
this one this one this one
if you were a transformer you'd be
optimus fine
spotted by thanks yeah
and i'd be optimus fugly
optimus datty boy
and i just wish someone would give me
one
no thank you
nice thank you no frank
don't thank me thank someone else
because i was asking you
okay
no way
[ __ ] it out bro
i've seen his i've seen his undercover
cover a couple times yeah he's on the
conference he's got busy busy couple
times bro it's hilarious he's a funny
brand couple times yeah yeah tick
that's too funny bro that's i couldn't
believe it kissed her kneecap through
her ripped jeans her ripped jeans so man
was like
[Music]
about thought think about the the
process of thought you're going through
here
so face to face you're leaning in
you're thinking i'm going to lips i'm
going to lips on the lips
rash is not leaning in rash is not
leaning in rash is not leaning in i'm
going to back out
i'm too fast
i can't back out i can't even drapes for
the hug because it's too big
let me lay a head on a nap
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
just [ __ ]
did he stay there did he come back up
hit if you have to lay on the knee for a
bit you have to kiss
and then lay on it and then suffer
remember you'll see tears dropping down
my head
she'll feel it on her knees
because i'm just crying
nah
yeah okay this is the thing
in my opinion i could be wrong
this is what i'm gonna get my fresh and
fit hat on yeah these toxic [ __ ] this
one gonna get my hat on yeah if you're
bra because i've been a nervous guy in a
day in a situation where everyone else
nervous
and i've moved like a [ __ ] off everyone
has
if you're moving nervous
and you do something it doesn't have to
be as bad as that if you do something
better
the best in my opinion i could be wrong
but i'm certain i'm not the best
possible thing you can do
is come completely clean
and be like
fam
wipe your tear
sit up and be like look
i just leaned in for a lips yeah and you
didn't move
i was too embarrassed to back out so i
just kept moving and the first things my
lips touched was your knee what's your
kneecap i'm embarrassed you're
embarrassed are we literally not
no
bless let's watch the thing let's watch
the thing go chat to me don't chat to me
let's watch the thing
you can't be just lips and a knee and
then allowing her to leave the yard and
attack the group chats with that the
group chat would be
pop because you're done in this town
you're done in these streets you're done
at it that's it
that's your lot that's the first
impression over and done with over and
over you have to come clean over now you
can never lipstick you can never lips
are friends you can have a bag anyone in
there you're never banging anyone anyone
you're done you're done because she
shouted her ex immediately after that
there's no form of referral
there's no form of riff you're done
you're done you're done you're done so
just enjoy it i hope it was worth it
because you're done
when all you need to do is just come
clean and be like fam
what was that was that did you just see
me kiss your knee what actually just
happened then if you want to lips me
tell me if you don't want to lift me
tell me
car i can't lift your knee again yeah
because i'm a grown man i can't i can't
be out of lips and patellas it's just
not going to work doesn't matter you
have to grab some formula
you have to be naked
oh yeah you have to be naked i'm clearly
lips and everywhere
i can't just lips
the only skin that's available through
your ripped jeans
that's a veil i'm a man
i'm a whole man
but yeah that's embarrassing but um
just before we wrap up let's do a
a fan request i've got okay
um okay cool so real quick
um
hi guys i've got a bit of a dilemma and
i would love to hear your two cents
i'm 32 i'm a 32 year old single mom
i've been single for about a year now
okay my ex of five years is 34 years old
and is now dating a 23 year old
he's
yeah pipe in that yeah he's
reinvigorated i don't know what you
thought we you i don't know what you
thought our response would be when you
wrote that in but it's probably not the
reaction you got fam
he's
he's banging her but waiting there but
wait okay say hello
i'm excited for him
after going through six months of
self-healing i put myself back on the
market looking to meet someone
i started going out more and my
instagram stroke tick-tock is a bit more
suggestive
now i consider myself above average
looking
and i'm pulling quite a few hotties
the only thing is they're literally all
ages 19 to 21.
now i'm definitely down
for just a good time but also open to
get into a relationship
if i meet the right sort of guy so my
questions are what's the deal with these
young cats all coming to
is there a common older chick fetish i
don't know about
should i be asking stroke telling my age
before we meet up
yeah it's not on my instagram but it's
definitely all over my tick tock
and am i wasting
time with these boys and am i gonna
embarrass myself
uh also for context i consider myself
quite independent stable healthy income
and i take care of my looks let me see
her fam let me [ __ ] say
fam literally
i was gonna say when i read this the
first time i intentionally didn't look
at her page because
i already know she's buff yeah from the
way she's chatting yeah yeah she has to
be baffled so i'm going to look first
and then i'm not seeing her no okay i
don't hear what you said i thought you
because i thought you've seen it now you
mean no no no no i haven't seen anything
let me see what the [ __ ] she looks like
oh she is buff
18 to 21 or 19 to 21 years i'm not
surprised
is there some form of older fetish i
don't know about where you've been
living every guy
on planet earth wants the [ __ ] milf
yeah what's this i don't know about
every guy like we're coming to an age
where it's no longer been gonna be a
melting it's just gonna be a an old an
old guy [ __ ] an older woman which is
annoying me yeah we're getting older
we're getting old
big man let me see this woman hang on
fam i'm still looking
she's bad still uh
did she do ninja warrior
she did do ninja warrior let me see this
woman cause you're so mad hang on fam
i'm not finished bro
what are these flags australian german
and is that filipino oh it is filipino
[ __ ] and she said a tick tock's a bit
suggestive she got link tree in there
let me see that big one let me see the
instagram hang on
let me see the tick tock first she says
suggestive
potatoes must be bouncing in one of the
videos hang on
five seven
five seven
oh is that that is that a height
yeah five seven australian yeah oh i
thought you meant she got five seven mil
um on that
oh what nah
um
oh no i accidentally came off her ting
hang on
hang on
all right you can peep the page now
thank you yes she's bath man
you said
[Music]
yeah she's buff
she's 32. yeah yeah no fam there's i
don't think there's an age group that
wouldn't want to [ __ ] her yeah exactly
there isn't
but to be fair if she's getting she's
got a busy she's got like 200 000 on
tick tock okay tick tock for a younger
generation of course of course
she's probably getting moved to through
instagram but they've they've channeled
this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of course
that's probably what it is of course let
me um
checker tick tock new tick tock account
exact account which only click utics now
tick tock
that's good
the insta is actually better than the
sick talk
so i haven't got the energy to look
they're all videos i've lost it anyway
but yeah um i get the premise um she's
banging um so to answer the question
she said is it uh
is it a thing where
they want to [ __ ] older older women or
slime yeah she said is it a fetish thing
like why basically why are all these
young guys trying to bang me yes and no
one my age
i come down i'm down for a good time so
banging a young guy i'm assuming is not
out of her out of question for her
um
but also she's down for something
serious if it happens so listen listen
darling everyone wants to bang you
regardless of the age group let's just
put that out there everyone every age
group wants the banking strategy the
younger generation just want to bang you
because they already know that you know
that they can't provide anything for you
so it's just going to be a bang if them
30 to 35 year old mandom start moving to
you
they know that you know that it's not
just going to be a bang for you so they
have to also come with something else
than just the bang so they can't just
say ah they can't just flirt with you
and talk to you in a in that kind of way
because you know there's an authorial
motive you have did you say she's a
single mom or a child she's a single mom
so she's going to have her priorities
straight she's not going to be wanted to
wait quote-unquote waste her time but
she also wants to have fun so the
younger generation are just providing
dick and no hassle so there's there's
course for entertainment in that sector
but if it's the 30 to 35 region at
hollering you
she's gonna yes entertain them but also
she may expect more hence the reason why
some of the older men not even gonna
bother hollywood yeah if i was 35 and i
came across your instagram
unless i'm loaded i'm not gonna bother
yeah because i just know your dms are so
busy well she's got like nearly 34 000
followers on instagram oh wow so it's
like i'm not gonna bother yeah unless i
get cake yeah and this is just normal
for me yeah because i already know that
i'm good looking
i'm loaded
and i probably have a big instagram
following myself or social media
following like unless i'm in that
category unless he's the male version of
her basically
he's not gonna bother
whereas young guys
they've got nothing to lose
so they're gonna shoot their shot and it
literally doesn't matter if you pie them
or not because they're gonna they're
they're in that element
they're sending 12 dms an hour it
doesn't really [ __ ] matter today yeah
yeah they're just trying to [ __ ]
whereas like yeah a guy that's of your
age group
he's got he's got to bring up in his
opinion he's got to bring a lot to the
table he has to he has to
he's got to bring a lot to the table
so um
like she competes in like fitness
competitions and [ __ ] she's not she's
banging she's in australia she's got a
kid australia is where it's at
apparently is where it's at but yeah
how do i explain it um
yeah if you want to bang the younger
guys by the younger guys all good but it
may be a situation where you might have
to shoot your shot
with an older buff guy
because he's just not gonna bother like
yeah take it from people who know like
we're 30 now we're in your age bracket
that you're looking for yeah we're in an
age bracket
and you you're crazy if you think
like even if i was like busy in these
streets you're crazy if i you think i'm
coming across someone
and i'm just talking i'm not even
talking about no offense like obviously
we're not
we're not famous
but we have
us like a half a step up from your
average dude who's 30.
in terms of sliding into dm's yeah yeah
yeah nothing else just in terms of
sliding we may have a little bit of an
edge yeah a little bit but what i'm
saying is
even with that little bit of edge you're
mad if you think i'm signing your dms
because i can't be asked to get pied
because guys get pied so often every day
they have to pick their battles yeah so
they're gonna slide into someone's dm
they ain't gonna be yours yeah yeah yeah
because that's a that's an instant pie
yeah it has to be someone that they know
is that they have a chance they have a
chance and they know they're probably
gonna bang within the next yeah it has
to be likely that it's gonna pattern
yeah so unless he is literally like i
said the male version of you it's just
like what's what's the point in putting
myself out there so you can like pie me
mm-hmm there's no point like look at you
you're banging like there's just there's
literally no point you're looking for
millionaires yeah that's what's in their
head so it may be a case where if you
see someone you like on social media you
might have to shoot the first shot and
then once once you've landed in the dms
and he sees that
it's a waiting game now yeah he'll snap
you up there you go they just like you
up so um
that's the reason why these youngers are
just all up in your dms well they're
gonna wanna yeah because they've got
nothing to lose they've got nothing to
do they're trying to clap cheeks because
period they're they're they're they're
yeah they're winter loss ratio they're
not in that backyard yeah they're not
they're not tired of abuse yet yeah i
mean they're so young and hungry yeah
yeah they haven't felt the scorn of
after yeah it's getting pied after part
of the fight someone in the 30s they've
got time for that don't they they've
been they've got too many other things
to do yeah they've got so much stuff to
think about bills to pay yeah yeah these
20 years they ain't got a job
so all they've got is time yeah time and
dick to give yeah time and dick to give
yeah that's it but yeah
my suggestion what our suggestion would
be shoot your shot first and i promise
you tables will turn immediately find
literally the way you look
find anyone
find any guy you find attractive on
instagram slide him a dm
he will respond he'll respond he will
it's basic it's basically it's just math
he will respond so um anyway thank you
very much for that guys thank you so
much for your attention thank you for
your time we love you we're going to
leave you yeah and next week uh foo has
got some tweets that i've been tweeting
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and we've
got some other fun stuff for you as well
so please guys again
baba birmingham
preferably central you can get it done
in 35 reliable high low fade whatever it
takes all the works um but anyway guys
love love love see you on thursday
[Music]